as I'm hopefully gonna show I think the
Cartesian approach is much more
difficult okay
but there is one saving grace that the
Cartesian approach has which is that all
I do is I make a point on the ellipse
because I've been Cartesian terms I've
got no theta to speak up right so I'm
just gonna call this my x1 y1 that's the
point I'm interested in now okay and I
want to find the equation of the tangent
there again I've got the point I just
need the gradient right now being that I
am ugh
I'm not allowing myself to use these
packaging forms I don't agree theater
involved I now have no choice remember
how I said that this is not set up
nicely for differentiation I'm just
gonna have to deal with him now okay
what I'm gonna call on is something I
introduced a little bit ago and I said
wasn't necessary but here is gonna be a
huge help I'm gonna use implicit
differentiation or this okay
if proceed differentiations can be very
useful because then I don't need to make
Y the subject I could just differentiate
as it is and then Apple will unfold
so watch okay first step I'm going to
try and put as many steps I can hear
something nothing is to keep talked
about I'm gonna differentiate every
single term please respect to X
something to go drdx of this plus DDX of
this equals d DX of that okay now just
I'm writing this out kind of any a
painfully obvious so you can see this is
the operation being applied to
everything differentiation is just an
operator just like logs and
Exponential's and multiplication you
just do fancy things with it okay it's a
lot it's more important not less so
having a look at this two parts of this
are easy and one part is a bit weird
looking so let's tackle them one at a
time I think this is the easiest what's
the different beauty with like that
it's a constant so it vanishes away
that's good yeah
even though it's been messy that one on
a squared is just a constant so really
one of different charities x squared
agreed
what's the derivative of x squared 2x
okay 2x and that one on a squared just
hangs off all right okay let me get to
this guy okay now just don't write this
part down but I'm gonna just so that we
have my brains don't get too full again
I want you to recognize the water would
be squared just the constant I could
take that in a way is that okay right so
don't write this bit down but this is
what we're calculating do you agree with
that okay now why is just it's not just
the numeral VI it's not just a pretty
much it's also itself a function of X
right so therefore I need to apply chain
rule to that remember what I said when I
introduced implicit of magician I said
there's a fancy name for the chain rule
so what I do this right don't worry
about if you'll just do just to get the
foot what do I do with this what do you
what just chain rule tell me to do with
this okay so I'm gonna differentiate the
outside first so you bring that power
down in fact I'm gonna write it here
whether we can do it time you got the
one on P Square bring power down so I
write then when I do a power find one
good give it used by one that's the
outside and then I've got to do that the
inside yeah the inside function
let your do one of these but the outside
function is called Y right so therefore
it's just dy on D X that's the
derivative of the inside function right
whatever it happens to be but the whole
point of this it is oh yeah
that's actually the thing I want right
that do you want to give da da there is
so now all I need to do is just rewrite
over how am I gonna rearrange this I'll
give you a second see what
do that to make do idea to something go
ahead
so let's notice a couple of things
firstly firstly the weirdest thing about
implicit differentiation is that you end
up getting wise or theaters or whatever
your other variable was do they're not
getting them in the derivative that's
kind of strange we're not used to that
but that's because we differentiate it
while the X's and Y's will entangle with
each other so it's no surprise you end
up with both within your derivative
that's their problem for the excess of
Y's I know exactly what the X and the y
are like they're just some numbers so I
just put them in okay the second thing
I've got hospitals it's negative its
negative did I expect it to be negative
now you can work out with me with that
without touching any like out there or
anything like that that it should be
negative it absolutely should be
negative and I'm going to use this
diagram to help me okay think about this
remember a and B real numbers
agreed so therefore a squared square are
positive yes so therefore I don't have
to worry about those in terms of
affecting the sign of this cuz that's
not going to work out now I really
figure out the X&Y
okay now for instance the particular
tension that I have drawn is in the
first quadrant agreed that means an x
and y are both positive does that
gradient look negative to you it does
right there's another quadrant that will
also give me a negative gradient where
is it it's quadrant three right what do
you know about x and y in quadrant three
if both negative so you see their
negatives will cancel maybe even this
guy and then of course you can rehearse
this for quadrant two and for one of
them t- which will cancel with the
negative at the front giving you the
positive tangents which we'd better get
does that make sense so you use these
things you silly geometry to your
advantage
don't just a pill to well do I have to
just look at all my lines to make sure I
didn't make an arithmetic mistake